I think homophobia can actually be kind
of dangerous you know a friend of mine
he's kind of a tough guy he went
skydiving recently he's like yeah I'm
not strapping some guy in my back that's
super gay now he's dead
sometimes I wish I was gay you know I
got fired from my last job for sexual
harassment I told a woman she had nice
cleavage they fired me which pissed me
off because my gay friends at work would
get away with murder they're like hey
Shelly how are you honk honk
it's like what why is that okay like
well not attracted to women I was like
so what I'm not attracted to kids I
can't go to a playground hey Timmy oh
yeah
[Applause]
I don't get stuff like that you know I
uh I'm trying to learn but like like
you're a woman wouldn't you rather be
complimented by a group that's into you
I don't care if a lesbian compliments me
nothing gets lesbians but that doesn't
help my ego you know you know but
lesbian's like hey Mark like a haircut
I'm like I know you have the same one
get off